cuando usted tiene entendió que las
tropas rusas habían ocupado su pueblo en
lugangs empezó a vivir en su piel la
guerra y se escapó pero no se fue lejos
decidió convertirse en voluntaria para
ayudar a civiles cercanos a la frente de
batalla
[Música]
por qué estamos aquí hemos venido a
ayudar a las personas de los territorios
retomados
porque nosotros también solíamos vivir
en la región de entendemos lo duro que
es
chica
dura también fuera decisión de Larissa
que hace un año se unió a las más de
40.000 mujeres que forman parte del
ejército ucraniano 5000 de las cuales
combaten en el frente su principal tarea
es entrenar a nuevos soldados
He dejado atrás mi vida de antes lo hice
después de que nuestro país vecino hizo
algo que fue una sorpresa atacarnos
y pañales
Aún es muy pronto para saber qué
consecuencias tendrá la guerra a largo
plazo sobre las mujeres ucranianas
Ucrania tiene un largo camino a recorrer
49 de 62 en la posición que ocupa el
índice de desigualdad de género en el
mundo según la ONU
pero algo podría estar cambiando con 34
años y en plena guerra a Lena es la
única jefa de policía de Ucrania
coordina el trabajo de 1500 agentes casi
en su totalidad hombres
si has elegido el camino del oficial de
policía este trabajo tienes que estar
las 24 horas los 7 días no diría que es
difícil es lo que hacemos
la invasión rusa de Ucrania provocó un
desplazamiento masivo de mujeres a
Europa y Rusia para las que han decidido
quedarse la lucha es y será recuperar el
hogar de millones de ucranianos